l'objectif est très ambitieux même dans
l'un des pays les plus verts de la
planète
oslo ne se donne que quelques années
pour devenir carboneutre
c'est à dire réduire le plus possible
ses émissions de co2 et trouver des
façons de compenser pour ce qui sera
quand même rejeté dans l'atmosphère
[Musique]
pour arriver à concocter cette recette
sous a réuni les meilleurs ingrédients
l'objectif changer les habitudes de vie
de ses habitants
pour y arriver il faut d'abord réduire
les distances nécessaires au déplacement
oslo au vu des quartiers denses et
compactes dans lesquelles les résidents
peuvent rapidement trouver tout ce dont
ils ont besoin pour les déplacements ce
qu'on vous souhaite que ça se passe dans
un esprit de mobilité verte c'est-à-dire
marché faire du vélo prendre le train le
tramway ou encore l'autobus les moyens
de transport qu'ils ne devront plus
produire aucun gaz à effet de serre
d'ici une dizaine d'années
[Musique]
c'est bien clair les automobilistes ne
sont pas les bienvenus ici au
centre-ville d'oslo pour y entrer avec
une voiture il faut payer
et puis des centaines de places de
stationnement ont carrément disparu
remplacées par des espaces publics
mais attention la voiture conserve sa
place à oslo ce qu'on ne veut plus ce
sont des véhicules qui polluent la ville
fait donc beaucoup pour attirer les
voitures électriques jusqu'à leur
aménager des stationnements sous terre
autre ingrédient essentiel pour devenir
une véritable ville verte s'attaquer à
la consommation d'énergie de ces
édifices
les anciens comme les nouveaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette école par exemple a été construite
avec les meilleures techniques et les
technologies vertes de pointe
l'édifice est si bien isolé si bien
orientée pour profiter du soleil qu'il
produit plus d'électricité qu'elle n'en
consomme
ici les autorités jouent dur elles ne
font pas que souhaité des changements
elle en impose également avec des lois
parfois très strictes
même les déchets ménagers ont leur place
dans cette recette imaginée à oslo si on
insiste beaucoup sur le recyclage et le
compostage est ce ça permet d'éviter des
émissions de méthane dans les sites
d'enfouissement
et surtout ce qui n'est pas enfoui peut
être transformés en engrais par exemple
ou encore en carburant ce qui ne peut
pas être transformés et brûlé cette
chaleur et chauffe de l'eau par des
tuyaux elle réchauffe les appartements
et puis oslo espère capter les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre provenant de ces
incinérateurs pour les enfouir dans
seule façon de s'assurer qu'elle ne
contribue pas aux bouleversements
climatiques
[Musique]
combien réussir sa recette oslo vêtus
les haussiers des ingrédients qui sont
parfois difficiles à trouver
d'abord des citoyens et des élus motivés
et aussi beaucoup d'argent l'ironie et
c'est qu'une partie des millions de
dollars qui financent ces technologies
vertes est en fait de la vente de
pétrole de gaz naturel les sources
d'énergie qui sont loin d'être aussi
proche